well let's bring in Texas land
commissioner Dr Don Cunningham Dr you
have a very interesting job and
perspective what what is the scope of
your responsibilities and how you see
the federal government failing to do
what it needs to do for you to be able
to do your
job well thank you Dana it's great to be
on with you all today good morning to
all of your Watchers you know as the
general land commissioner I'm the
steward of 13 million Acres of state
land responsible for the majority of oil
and gas fund education help our veterans
and do a lot of other things but
uniquely
in this border fight you know the
islands in north of the center of the
Rio Grand um that have previously not
been claimed by Texas we claimed them a
few months ago giving our DPS and other
law enforcement access to those islands
trying to end the illegal migration that
is coming across them but I tell you
what what I see every single day is that
the Biden Administration not only hurts
our lovely border communities but they
are absolutely orchestrating almost
every bit of this Mass immigration you
know article 4 section 4 of our
constitution says that the federal
government should and will protect us
against Invasion and domestic terrorism
what we are seeing now is an absolute
abdication of their Duty and and if you
look recently even even just a few
months ago they made it easier for the
Chinese migrants to come across asking
them only five questions I believe
instead of 55 questions and we have to
realize that people from China don't
just walk out of their country it's who
their government allows them to come
across and when you see the aggressive
plans on China's 100-year plan about
really taking over um and getting into
military conflict with the US in their
100-year plan I think we all should
really worry about what's happening at
the border even more than that massive
Humanity that's coming across okay
Doctor um here is your Governor just
yesterday talking about the new steps
that Texas is um trying to do and what
the administration is trying to do in
response Joe Biden has spent no time
trying to stop illegal immigration he's
only spent time trying to stop Texas
from stopping illegal immigration they
might and they might be successful on
that point but you say this entire
Invasion as you call it is by Design is
that what you're trying to described To
Us by the Chinese Nationals who are
crossing
over absolutely when you look we know we
have an aggressive country um who's
looking um spying on us doing all these
types of things I think initiating acts
of War actually already they published
their plan a long time ago it's no
secret there's lots of literature on it
but I think Governor Abbott is exactly
right you know the the Biden
Administration is spending more effort
on trying to stop Texas and obeying our
laws and Constitution and they are't
actually obeying the Constitution
themselves and doing their Duty um you
know take for example we've seen just
about 140,000 deportations in 2023 to
put that in in context we had 300,000
people that we know of across our border
in December alone right so so these
court dates for these folks aren't until
2030 now that's how backed up they are
and so those people aren't going to
stick around for their court date in in
six years um and the numbers the numbers
are staggering and we visited every
day and we wonder when it's going to
stop and what bill just said about the
cartel is making the Millions
that they do by the week should it
should stun everybody watching this
story uh thank you for your time Dr
Buckingham I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme
and I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis